my absolute number one priority is  making sure that we deal with the  economic situation that we face at home  you know with more news of inflation  today it's the number one thing that's  on people's minds it's the thing that's  causing most anxiety opening up bills  seeing the emails come in with Rising  prices and that's why it's right that we  grip it and tomorrow the chancellor will  set out a plan that will enable us to do  that the next priority alongside that  has been a legal migration it's been the  thing that I've spent most of my time on  outside of preparing for the Autumn  statement and working with the  chancellor to do that I think that is a  priority for the British people and it's  something that they have my commitment I  will address